it's a party and everyone's invited it's
not my mouth though
so the first teaser trailer for Avengers
infinity war has finally landed after
they did some preview stuff that that
was at d23 it was a comic I can't even
remember a while ago but didn't release
that to the public so let's get right
into this thing I had a pretty big smile
on my face this is this is really what I
like to get in a teaser lots of hints
lots of nuggets lots of individual
things to show me you know who's
involved give me a little bit of a feel
of the thing but almost no plot points
and granted I'm just going bye-bye but
I'm also going by track record with how
marvelous handled is marketing up to
this point but I really get the vibe
that nothing that we see in this trailer
is from any later than halfway into the
movie if I would actually wouldn't be
surprised of everything we see is in the
first quarter of the movie which is what
I like in a trailer the more stuff you
show me from later on even if it is an
outright spoilery there's kind of a part
of my brain that won't relax until I've
seen in the movie all the bits that I
already saw in the trailer which means
it does sometimes drive me crazy with
stuff that was in the trailer doesn't
make the movie um you know I understand
stuff gets tough I understand why that
happens but just drives me crazy so
again the vibe of this I get is this is
all or at least up we're seeing
reactions from characters when you know
stuff is starting to go down this all
feels like gorillas we see we're seeing
scenes some of the early meetups I love
that it opens with Samuel Jackson with
Nick Fury's voice we don't actually even
see him but his voice felt like the
right one to start with we get lots of
cool little glimpses we get vision it's
sort of pulling like a looking more or
less full human thing and probably to
make the relationship he's building with
wanna not seem as weird so there's that
we get the the hair-raising on Peter
Parker's arms that's kind of the first
direct hint of the spider sense cuz that
can really come into play into
homecoming so maybe it's you know maybe
it's a new power form maybe it's
somebody he just didn't recognize before
and he's still coming to grips with we
see him in the
the ironman designed new armored suit
kind of thing which is okay
it's not bad I prefer his classic suit
well I say classic the one from
spider-man homecoming so I'm kind of
hoping that the the high tech suit well
the high tech suit that Tony Stark is
made either gets damaged or proves to be
too bulky or something in that hassen
digital back to his classic suit that's
it kind of what I'm hoping for but you
know there was that we get all these
glimpses of all these characters we see
what it looks like the way Bruce Banner
is gonna show up again he basically just
crashes into dr. Strange's house that's
cool I like that Wong's right there
there was a surprising amount of
supporting characters displayed just as
much as the main ones you would expect
to be there and there's a bunch of nice
little beats I love the line from Black
Panther and saying get this man a shield
and then Captain America steps forward
it really reminds me of line from John
wish chapter 2 which was also also in
the trailers for that we're um Laurence
Fishburne's that get this man a gun and
obviously the tone is a little bit
different in their delivery but it
reminded me that aim was a cool moment
in both trailers so I just felt like
tossing that out there we get glimpses
I'm never mind I'm not even gonna list
everybody that we see but I'd be quicker
for me to list the ones we don't see
that's a pretty small list but I like
where they sort of settled on four
little moments Black Widow got a little
moment which I liked I enjoyed that
we got Loki got a moment I want I don't
necessarily want to put spoiler warning
on this but I am gonna do a little bit
of I don't wanna say analysis a little
bit of guesswork based on what I'm
seeing here I don't usually give into
speculation cuz I I really try really
hard not to do that because I don't want
to accidentally ruin something by
putting too many pieces together but
like I said everything I get from the
vibe of these of these clips and these
bits is that it's all early stuff so I
seriously doubt I'm even if I'm right
that I'm spoiling anything later on but
we've got Loki holding the tesseract so
up obviously for the confirmation he
took the thing which is no big surprise
I think we all knew he did even though
we didn't see him do it at the end of
Thor Ragnarok
but the way
he's holding it for my money there's one
of two thick belt first of all I'm
calling right now that happens on the
ship that the Asgardians are on and one
of two things is going on or at least
there's the two most likely things then
there's what I'm hoping is going on but
I'll come back to that so one of two
things is going on either he is handing
the tesseract over to Thanos either
because it was always his plan to do
that or just to save his own neck that
would be the thing to do if they want to
stick with you know the squirrely can't
trust him you know self-serving Loki
which he's always been up to this point
I'm kind of hoping they don't do that
because that would sort of negate the
start of his developing more than that
at the end of the Ragnarok and I don't
like when character development gets
negated later on I always kind of rail
against that so I hope it's not that
alternately it's possible that he is
trying to use the tesseract to ward off
Thanos that might be a step too far in
the other direction because I don't
think he's prepared to go step up and be
all Noble and be like I will protect my
people so what I'm hoping is we're
getting a split between the two and what
I'm what I'm hoping is that Loki is
willingly giving the tesseract to Thanos
to save the other as guardians for my
money Thor has already been shot out
into space by Thanos and so he can be
picked up by the Guardians and Loki is a
look I know you're going to do horrible
things with this but leave my people
alone I do care about these people
they're all I have left of my of my home
so here take this and go away which i
think is a nice splitting in the
difference because it's self-serving and
it is a bit selfish and it's
short-sighted in a lot of ways but it is
by his standards a very noble thing even
though in the grand scheme of things bad
idea so I feel like that would be the
way to go with something like that so
let's let's talk about Santos now I've
expressed concern before about Thanos
initially because I'm not a big fan of
Josh Brolin there's nothing really wrong
with the guy I don't dislike him he just
doesn't really ever do anything for me
as a
former he's fine that's kind of it he's
fine he's neither he's neither blown me
away nor been a major detriment to
anything I've seen him in but having
said that I'm really digging his vocal
delivery and I'm loving these lines the
the lines that have been written for him
I love the line where he is saying you
know fun is not something you take into
account when you're preparing to
reconfigure the universe but this puts a
smile on my face that seems like a
terrific balance to get a great villain
because he's got some higher goal that
he's trying to accomplish for the record
I seriously doubt they're going to do
the he's literally in love with the
embodiment of death I think they're
gonna go for a more philosophical love
of the concept of death and not go the
route of oh here's a lady with a skull
forehead and he's in love with that I
doubt they're gonna do that but so he's
got a mission that in his mind is a
higher purpose because too many things
are alive in the universe more in the
eye I need to kill a whole bunch of
these things because that will reject
balance so he's got a goal he's got a
mission he's got a quest but he also
takes enjoyment in what he does and that
it's really good to have both because
having both can is a good way to get a
really memorable villain because
otherwise if you only do one or you only
do the other you tend to get somebody
who just feels like they're doing it for
the sake of it because they're evil and
they don't really seem to have to be
properly motivated beyond that or if
they're just driven by the quest they
don't seem to enjoy what they're doing
at all you can get well honestly you can
get some of the really bland villains
that Marvel has already gotten it's like
Malekith or like Ronan the accuser so I
think I really like the vibe I get off
of his lines that having been said there
was something I caught and it's not a
red flag let's call it pink flag and
that is that I noticed that even though
we hear his voice and we see him and he
looks pretty good I'm always kind of
iffy on 100% CGI created characters but
he looks pretty good for what we see but
we don't
him speak we don't see his lips move to
form words and that's as I said that's
kind of a pink flag for me because when
it comes to the uncanny valley and CGI I
think a lot of people they I hear people
always talk about the eyes all those
dead eyes huh that isn't what throws me
off with CGI created characters
it's the lips the lips never move right
and that more than anything can take me
because you can have a completely
photorealistic beautifully rendered
properly lit so it looks like it existed
in the Spain the same space interacting
with actors who know how to make it feel
like they're interacting with something
really there but then the lips start
moving and it still Yanks me completely
out of it Maz Kanata is a good example
of that from Star Wars of the force
awakens I know a lot of you are like oh
it will almost look real I'm like really
I my my eyes zero in on those lips I'm
like yeah so the fact that they didn't
show the lips the Paranoid in me wants
to say it's because they know it's not
gonna look good it's never gonna look
right and they're hiding it the optimist
in me cuz there is one he's malnourished
but there is an optimist in me somewhere
the optimist would say that they
understand that the lips are going to
need more time and more work to look
correct so let's not show them now
they'll be ready by the time the movie
comes out and I can't imagine is
entirely coincidental that there is a
sort of upper lip gate going on with the
Justice League movie and how bad the the
CGI removal of the the mustache for
Henry Cavill as Superman was now I am II
I'm to be fair to that movie the reason
that looks so bad wasn't because they
did bad work is because from when the
reshoots happens of the release they did
not nearly have enough time to get that
right but it did sort of bring extra
attention to this area when it comes to
trying to retrying to do cgi at all so i
i wouldn't be shocked if that was part
of the calculation just let's not show
him speak right yet whether it's for the
the reason I'm okay would which is it
will be fine later or the reason I'm
worried about which is it's never going
to
fine but okay moving on from that I'm
liking the the overall vibe of this
thing because you really do get the
sense like this is a massive be like
you're seeing all these characters all
having this all moments and reacting to
things they see immediately in front of
them or you know who's kind of looking
off in the distance who knows what
they're even looking at but we've
getting them all pulled together and I
the Avengers theme music is funny to me
because it's not a theme that I ever
really thought much about when I saw the
first Avengers movie but it's grown on
me over time and at this point I love it
and when that theme kicked in at the
very end I did get you know sort of the
the hairs on the back of my neck a
little bit
which is not common for me it happens
pretty rarely like the biggest one it
happened for me with was the first full
trailer - the force awakens the one with
the with Luke doing the voice-over about
the force being strong in his family
that gave me full-on goosebumps up and
down the back of my neck this was not
quite as potent but I did get that same
tingle which maybe I should ask a doctor
about huh
but I did sort of hit that same nerve
once that music kicked in and it's it's
funny cuz like I said I didn't think too
much of that theme first time I heard it
but I've heard enough and it's well used
enough that I've really kind of it's
grown on me much in the same way that I
think Danny Elfman's Spider Man theme
grew on me also doesn't think too much
of that first time I saw but you know by
the time it was that that series had
wrapped up at that hearing that theme
did make me go yeah so I ending on that
music and and the other thing about that
theme is that theme is triumphant and
uplifting so we're watching you know
these characters come together
here's Thanos things look like they're
getting worse and worse and worse and
then that theme heroes are coming that's
a great balance so that it's not just
being like the world will be destroyed
like no the world is in danger
here come the heroes now sort of a
button on the end of it with the
guardians of the galaxy I like more on
the rewatch because I have now watched
it four or five times if it had come out
early enough in the day where I could
have gotten a live recording before I
went to work I would have done a live
reaction but it didn't so and there was
go away I was gonna wait to watch this
stuff until I got home from work so yeah
my lunch break I watched it like five
times I don't know but it indicates that
initially it's sticking the guardians of
the galaxy at the end I was like oh okay
because it seemed like not a bad thing
but kind of a weak thing to sort of do
it as a final button on your trailer
after the title has been shown but then
I thought about it and it does make a
lot of sense because I I always have to
remember and this was the manager of my
myself about the reveal of spider-man in
the civil war trailer which is that not
everybody out there especially you know
your your standard mainstream movie
audience is like me they're not
following everything that's going on
about this movie before it even comes
out so to me that's a weak button cuz I
already know they're gonna be in this
but your average moviegoer might not and
even if they do it's still kind of a
nice note to end on because you get
really wrapped up in the trailer as it
goes along you you're seeing more and
more more characters as you see in
you're starting to get a sense of a
scope of the threat then the theme kicks
in you're like ah and because of the
guardians of the galaxy are the most
detached from the rest of the Marvel
Universe that's kind of a nice note to
have it as the final button because it
becomes a point of just going oh yeah
but don't forget these guys will be
there too because you know you wouldn't
logically think that you kind of have to
be told if you're not like me and
following all this stuff so yeah pretty
upbeat
I mean I'm I will be very blunt about
the fact that I am I'm really all in on
the Marvel movies at this point Marvel
Netflix has stumbled for me recently I I
actually have become highly skeptical of
the Marvel Netflix output but the the
movies to me III still I've not
regretted watching any of them they're
always at worst fun and sometimes
they're great I don't know if this one's
gonna be great because I mean there's a
massive cast this is a lot to juggle but
I do think it's gonna be fun
and it looks yeah I'm excited for this
one so those are my thoughts on the
Avengers infinity war trailer oh there
poster premiere - but it's bore
so I'm not gonna talk about the poster
but did you see it obviously you did but
so what were your thoughts on it
whatever they are drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it don't
forget to like subscribe check me out on
Twitter at council of geese give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
that is available on iTunes now Apple
podcasts it is now and stitcher radio
I'm also one half of the punch like a
girl podcast that is a presentation of
the firewater podcast network firing
water podcast.com I'm now on the
Stardust app because why not I'll give
it a shot
links for all this stuff will be down
below so until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]